what happened to this skull cracking
people exploding extended fight scene in
The Flash apparently it was just a
little too R rated for a PG-13 audience
The Flash was probably never intended to
push the PG-13 envelope the way that
some of the entries in the Snyder verse
did the mpa bestowed it with its genre
typical rating for sequences of violence
and action some strong language and
partial nudity and that's what viewers
can expect from The Flash but according
to co-star Sasha Kaye who plays Cara
zorel better known as Supergirl one of
its Central set pieces was originally
longer and was cut down to size in part
so that it wouldn't tip the movie into
R-rated territory during an interview
with collider paella was asked to Dish
about any noteworthy deleted sequences
from The Flash her answer is pretty
intriguing for fans who wanted to see
even more Supergirl or who wish that the
action in the movie was a little bit
harder hitting the silo scene was a lot
longer I did a lot of stunts for that
scene and some I think were a little too
rated R and they ended up kind of
bringing it in the scene in question
sees Kanye's Cara zorel being rescued
from a remote Russian prison while she
is weak and her powers are depleted when
Barry Allen and Company first find her
once she's taken outside and the
sunlight hits her body she regains her
abilities and lays ways to the guards at
the facility it's certainly a cathartic
scene and one that might have been even
more so had the movie not opted for a
less restrictive rating Kanye didn't go
into detail about what precisely made
the deleted content too over the top for
the theatrical version of The Flash but
it can probably be assumed that it was
just too violent she is a badass Kaye
doesn't seem to be too upset about some
of her stunt work getting cut from The
Flash but you can detect a bit of
wistfulness in her tone there were so
many and as much as I love stunts I
would love to see the wholeness of those
shots this brings up an interesting
question will we ever see the R-rated
cut of The Flash with Supergirl's uncut
takedown of her captors restored in the
days of extended directors Cuts Blu-ray
special features and flat out leaks it's
fairly commonplace for deleted scenes to
turn up eventually especially for big
Blockbusters like The Flash in this case
though it doesn't seem very likely
kaye's interview even implies this when
she says that she's holding out hope
that she'll one day be able to see the
cut shots if the star of the scenes in
question isn't even sure if she'll get a
look it doesn't sound like the rest of
us have much of a chance and that's a
shame because an R-rated cut of The
Flash might actually be an improvement
on the version that hit theaters this is
all speculation but perhaps the
overstuffed and occasionally muddy
multiversal elements of The Flash would
be a little clearer if it hadn't needed
to be cut down to secure a PG-13 rating
maybe with some more direct hard-hitting
violence the film's weak Final Act would
be more effective as well director Andy
musketti has also already alluded to
other deleted scenes during an interview
with real blind podcast so perhaps
similar to Barry's alternate timeline
rewrites there's a universe in which
some of the movies restored content
result and more enthusiastic reviews and
a bigger box office outcome but short of
a massive Snyder cut style
reconstruction the hypothetical R-rated
version of The Flash will probably have
to remain a product of an alternate
timeline to everyone in this segment of
the Multiverse but we can always hope do
you know what the symbol stands for
[Music]
foreign